have you heard of any of the third party
candidates they're not really important
because they're nobody so you're gonna
have to take the lesser of both evils in
my opinion the independent candidates
could only draw votes away from one or
the other candidates I don't want to
waste my vote and risk someone like
Donald Trump getting into office let's
say that there were a third party
candidate right who perfectly matched
your your values in which you fill your
conscience I would vote my conscience
I'm definitely looking for a third party
candidate Gary Johnson I believe he
looks promising in an election year in
which the two mainstream candidates are
disliked at never-before-seen levels
might there be an opportunity for third
party candidates former governor Gary
Johnson is pulling close to double
digits higher than any other third party
candidate since Ross Perot in 1992 we
hit the streets of Los Angeles and the
campus of UCLA to ask voters whether
they consider voting third party this
year and to administer the I side with
comtesse an online quiz that shows you
which candidate is your ideological
match based on your answers to a series
of questions can we take a little
political quiz basically this will match
you are based on what you're like with
Canada what's your stance on abortion
absolutely it should be allowed for the
proper reasons do you support the
legalization of same-sex marriage yeah
should the government continue to fund
Planned Parenthood
yeah do you support Obamacare yeah
should the US accept refugees from Syria
not at this time should the government
raise the federal minimum wage yes
should prisons banned the use of
solitary confinement for juveniles no be
some badass kids around do you support
the legalization of marijuana I do
absolutely
sure oh oh definitely
I call it that based on that quiz what
do you think you're going to be most
aligned with which candidate Hillary the
way to go if it came out that you were
more aligned with a third party
candidate would you look more deeply
into them or it's still off the table I
think it's I think it's off the table I
just don't think that a third party
candidate has the votes to win and
instead is going to possibly take the
votes away from somebody who are from
Hillary while committed Clinton
partisans seemed unlikely to budge we
found that many of the folks we talked
to identified as independents a trend
consistent with data that points to
fewer and fewer Americans affiliating
with the major parties do you identify
it as a Democrat independent because I
feel it's more important to care about
issues do you still consider yourself a
Republican and not just not a Donald
Trump fan or are you an independent I'm
more of an independent now I'm sort of
an independent but I lean more towards
the left so ya know I don't identify as
either one of them I just know that the
system that we've seen in the past has
failed us and I just believe that we
need real change whatever that looks
like
and these self-described independents
were more willing to at least hear out
the third party candidates in fact a
recent Quinnipiac poll found that 61% of
Americans want Gary Johnson on the
debate stage despite the fact that the
Commission on Presidential Debates sets
the polling cutoff at fifteen percent
should the presidential debates include
candidates with less than fifteen
percent support yes everybody who can
get their voice and I think that
deserves to should I don't think so no
yes especially now with you know third
party candidates providing another
choice for people of a party where they
may not agree with who the nominee is
will perhaps be more honest reflection
of how people really feel would you
still agree with that if you thought
that they were going to siphon off votes
from Hillary Clinton I would
I mean you know fair is fair being in
Los Angeles we didn't find many
libertarians but we did find many people
who aligned with the Green Party's Jill
Stein so apparently you agree with Jill
Stein 97% of the time oh wow that is
your top one
Hillary is 92 so she's pretty close and
then Garry Johnson is third at 73 before
a huge drop to Donald Trump at 28% for
Jill Stein you actually agree with Jill
Stein 77% of the time that's your number
one number two is Garry Johnson you
agree with the third party candidates
significantly more than either Trump or
Hillary and again I think a lot of
America does but I think again it's it's
the corporation's of things that will
put these people in front of us your
results are what you expected you agreed
with Hillary 90% of the time that's even
better than I thought I'm a philosophy
major
I'm very Aristotelian so I'm dealing
more with the virtues of a person would
you vote for somebody that with whom you
disagree on policy but you thought was
trustworthy and that's right character
and had the right virtues and had a
voice I would much rather they be voted
in than somebody who registers for ideas
and then just wants to be elected and
follow the problem yeah overall in this
quiz with all the you know for tens of
thousands of people that have taken it
Gary Johnson is ranked the highest on
integrity honesty intelligence
leadership does that make you want to
take a hear him speak you hear passion
and the voice and through the eyes which
are the windows the soul so I need to
see the way he moves the way he talks
before I can start saying ok that man
has my
but you'll consider I'll consider once I
see him do you think that people should
vote their conscience if even if they
can't win there's no chance I think it's
still worth a shot it's nice knowing
that people in you my younger generation
are identifying as independence and not
just blindly following whatever the
party agrees with and I think a lot of
Bernie supporters trying to find some
banner to go under now and I think
neither Jill Stein or Carrie Johnson
third party candidates have a good pool
of people they can reel into their
dinner parties
we're reflective of most Americans which
is speaking with a broad brush stroke is
being fiscally conservative socially